With a famously conservative lead actor,
Sound of Freedom was already on the path to
controversy. Add a dash of QAnon affiliation,
and it's no surprise that the 2023 action
flick is raising eyebrows across the globe.
Sound of Freedom is one of 2023's most
unexpected success stories. Within two
weeks of its July 4th release, the
independent action-thriller grossed
over $85 million at the box office and brought
Jim Caviezel back into the Hollywood spotlight.
The former The Passion of the
Christ star plays Tim Ballard,
a former government agent who goes rogue to take
down a child trafficking ring. While Caviezel
himself has become known for his inflammatory
politics, his character draws inspiration from
a real-life figure who's dedicated his career to
a very particular and controversial line of work.
Tim Ballard is a former undercover operative
for the U.S. Department of Homeland Security.
After leaving the government agency, he
founded Operation Underground Railroad,
a nonprofit organization that's
dedicated to fighting real-life
human trafficking rings all around the world.
Of course, Ballard's work has also made him a
source of controversy. He's outspoken about his
politics and he's been linked to conspiracy
theories pertaining to the exploitation of
children. For this reason, Sound of Freedom
has attracted its fair share of critics, some
of whom have big names. Rolling Stone succinctly
summarized their thoughts on the film, writing,
"The QAnon-tinged thriller about
child-trafficking is designed to
appeal to the conscience of
a conspiracy-addled boomer."
"God's children are not for sale."
There are aspects to Sound of Freedom's
plot that are quite representative of how
Ballard's story is reported to have transpired.
As the film depicts, Ballard really did quit his
job at the Department of Homeland Security in
order to carry out a rescue mission. However,
it's the mission in question that starts
to separate the film from reality.
In Sound of Freedom, Ballard quits his job
to rescue a young girl from the hands of
a Colombian child trafficking organization.
However, while speaking to The Daily Signal,
Ballard explained that his federal superiors told
him to abort missions in both Haiti and Colombia,
which he refused to do as he felt it
defeated the purpose of his duties.
Ballard described both those missions as
"major cases," which could have had huge
impacts on human trafficking worldwide. When he
received instructions to come home, he refused.
In the same interview, Ballard revealed that he
was able to carry out the missions
thanks to funding from Glenn Beck,
a conservative political commentator who's
worked for CNN, Fox News, and TheBlaze TV.
After completing the rescues, Ballard
formed Operation Underground Railroad
in 2013. According to the foundation's
website, the group works with government
and law enforcement agencies, both
domestically and internationally,
to devise strategies that will assist
in the fight against human trafficking.
These strategies include gathering intelligence,
offering resources, and providing care
to survivors. They've also been known to
carry out sting operations and share the
footage of their rescues on social media.
While the Operation Underground Railroad's efforts
seem noble in theory, they have also been the
subject of some controversy. Most notably,
the organization has been linked with QAnon,
a far-right conspiracy theory movement
that believes Democratic politicians
and Hollywood celebrities are involved in
the operation of child trafficking rings.
Ballard and Operation Underground Railroad have
denied any association with the movement, but
their methods for researching and spreading the
word about human trafficking are markedly similar.
Discussing QAnon with The New
York Times, Ballard even stated,
"Some of these theories have allowed
people to open their eyes. So now
it's our job to flood the space with real
information so the facts can be shared."
These days, however, even Ballard appears to be
distancing himself from Operation Underground
Railroad. Vice reported that he parted ways
with the organization before Sound of Freedom
was released, and he has since co-founded
a new endeavor known as The Spear Fund.